[Music]
impeachment it turns out was a very
central part of the Constitution of the
United States
meaning it's obscure people don't know
about it but it probably was necessary
for the Constitution actually to be
ratified by the American people you can
see the impeachment Clause and I'm going
to explain its content in a moment but
you can see it as part of the American
Revolution itself in the sense that the
revolt against a king who was a leader
who had authority over We the People was
incomplete if we didn't have a mechanism
by which we could get rid of our leaders
including the president which was a way
of ensuring we didn't have anything like
a monarchy now the way impeachment
worked is that in the early American
colonies before America was America
we started impeaching people who were
following orders from the king and what
that meant was that an abuse of
authority would be called out by some
Legislative Assembly and in the initial
phase what would happen would be there
just be a vote that the person had
abused authority and then if the thing
fell to completion and this goes back to
England there'd be a trial and in the
trial the person would be convicted of
the offense for which impeachment was
had and if convicted the person would be
removed from office so to bring this
back to the American structure as that
developed after the Revolution and after
the Constitution came into place and
this was thought through with such care
in Philadelphia when the Constitution
was debated the idea was that if there
is a high crime and misdemeanor and we
can talk a bit about what that means or
if there's treason or bribery then the
House of Representatives by majority
vote can impeach the president the
vice-president Supreme Court justices
members of the cabinet and what that
means is there's a kind of official
judgment that the person has done
something very very bad and after that
first the proceeding moves to the Senate
which is acting like a court and which
decides whether to convict which means
to remove the person from office the
house makes the impeachment vote by a
majority vote that doesn't mean anyone
has to leave office it then goes to the
Senate which if it votes by a two-thirds
majority to convict on the ground on
which the let's say President was
impeached then the person is as they say
about baseball's that are hit very hard
the president is gone yes so because the
word high crimes and misdemeanors seems
to mean kind of felonies high crimes and
misdemeanors the normal current reader
would think oh is there a crime if you
go back to the 18th century it's
actually a lot more inspiring like that
than that and kind of fitting with a
system that's committed to
self-government so if there's a crime
let's call it jaywalking or shoplifting
or not paying your income taxes that's
not a high crime or misdemeanor in the
constitutional sense what is meant by
high crime and misdemeanor is an abuse
of official authority and shoplifting or
income tax evasion that's a crime it's
not an abuse of official authority if
the president the United States let's
suppose decides I'm gonna pardon every
police officer who's shot an African
American that's not itself likely to be
a crime the president has the pardon
power but that is definitely an
impeachable offense in fact James
Madison spoke of abuse of the pardon
power as an impeachable offense if the
president the United States decides I'm
gonna go on vacation in Paris for the
next six months because it's really
beautiful that's certainly not a crime
but it's an impeachable offense that's
an egregious
of the authority of the office so abuse
of the authority of the office if it's
egregious pardon power example would be
one if the president starts invading
civil liberties in a terrible way by
locking people up for insufficient
reason by going crazy in terms of
security measures at airports and
borders and by going crazy I'm using
that as kind of a legal term of art
really exceeding the bounds of the
reasonable that is not a crime but that
is an abuse of authority and there were
right back in the impeachment clause
which is I think first and foremost a
way of preserving our rights and
liberties and a way of calling out an
authority who has invaded them think now
about what the American Revolution was
fought for so I've spent a lot of last
months in the 18th century and the
people back then were on the impeachment
issues and presidential authority issues
they were off the charts good in the
debate in Virginia on whether we should
ratify the Constitution one really
learned person said we cannot ratify
this Constitution and the reason is the
pardon power and it was urged by the
skeptic the president could participate
in something really sinister with one of
his advisors then his advisors in legal
trouble and then the president can
pardon the person for engaging in
illegal or corrupt activity that the
president initiated how can we allow a
Constitution that has that in it that's
a fair question and it was stated with
great precision as an objection to the
Constitution as I recall by someone who
had actually signed the Declaration of
Independence and I know that person was
at the Constitutional Convention and
refused to embrace it
James Madison very quietly responded and
he said I think the gentleman has
overlooked something isn't that a sweet
way
responding to someone when the stakes
are super high whether we're gonna have
a constitution the gentleman has
overlooked something and then Madison
explained if the president uses the
pardon power to shelter someone who's
done something terrible there's
something available in the Constitution
impeachment and Madison actually did his
interlocutor one better the interlocutor
was saying if the president advises
something terrible and participates it
and then pardons the person isn't that
awful Madison said yes that's awful
that's impeachable Madison's words seem
to go beyond that to say if you pardoned
someone who's who's done something
terrible or one of your own people
that's itself a legitimate grounds for
impeachment which suggested that abuse
of the pardon power in the words of
James Madison that's an impeachable
offense and with respect to the meaning
of the Constitution it is hazardous to
argue with James Madison the beauty of
the impeachment mechanism is its
connection with the principle that we
have a Republican not a monarchy which
means it puts we the people in charge
that means that invocation of the
impeachment mechanism whether it's a
Democratic president or Republican
president really depends on We the
People so if you think of examples there
was some interest in under President
Bush and President Obama some interest
in teaching them but I think you know
thank goodness we the people even if we
didn't like either of those presidents
didn't think there was an impeachable
offense under President Nixon by
contrast and I believe very
unfortunately under President Clinton
because he didn't commit an impeachable
offense but under both of them there was
a public demand for getting rid of them
on the ground
president nixon had abused his
presidential authority to cover up
crimes and also had himself used
presidential authority to invade civil
rights and civil liberties that got
people whatever their political
affiliation sufficiently charged up that
they either were willing to go along
with those members of the House of
Representatives who wanted to impeach
Nixon or they fueled that in the Clinton
case there was a thought and again
perjury and obstruction of justice which
were the charges against President
Clinton there's nothing good about them
they're very bad but they weren't in his
case impeachable offenses under the
Constitution nonetheless people were
charged up a lot of people were charged
up so whether the president is a
democrat or republican whether it's
President Trump or in the future you
know some left-of-centre president if
people think that there's something that
really is beyond the pale and that's not
the constitutional test but it's the
kind of koloko way of getting at the
constitutional test beyond the pale of
legitimate uses of authority then we the
people were the boss so the question
who's the boss the first three words of
the Constitution say it We the People
and the impeachment Clause kind of makes
that real
you